les automobilistes auront bientôt un
raccourci pour passer d'un quartier à
l'autre de ce secteur de longueuil les
travaux de prolongement du boulevard
béliveau avance rondement depuis la fin
de l'été
aux grandes mains de ceux qui veulent
protéger cette petite grenouille
menacées d'extinction tous les habitants
de rien notre religion l'essentiel des
acteurs de rainette faux grillon a
détruit par un développement
domiciliaire
longueuil attend le prolongement de ce
boulevard depuis des dizaines d'années
que des véhicules qui sont tout
simplement en transit à travers dans des
quartiers résidentiels où circulent des
vélos des enfants ça tout simplement pas
de bons conseils rien pour convaincre
des groupes environnementaux qui demande
à ottawa de faire cesser les travaux
nous exhortons aujourd'hui le
gouvernement fédéral à agir rapidement
et par décret en vertu de la loi sur les
espèces en péril
une source a confié à radio canada que
le gouvernement trudeau s'apprête à
promulguer un décret d'urgence qui
mettrait un terme à tout développement
dans le secteur comme il l'a fait à la
prairie en 2016 d'ailleurs le ministère
fédéral de l'environnement confirme
avoir entrepris des discussions avec
québec la ville de longueuil tient à
rappeler qu'elle a reçu l'aval des deux
paliers de gouvernement pour aller de
l'avant avec le projet
si à les termes mêmes du ministère déjà
change d'idée en cours de route désolé
mais nous c'est pas la responsabilité de
la ville de devoir le changer de cap ou
gréogry de l'opinion des uns et des
autres la ville de longueuil a construit
ce corridor de biodiversité pour
permettre aux rennais de faux grillon de
passer d'un côté à l'autre du boulevard
béliveau mais des groupes
environnementaux met en doute la
capacité des grenouilles de trouver ce
passage vers le boisé du tremblay c'est
pas une espèce qu'une grande capacité de
déplacement alors le corridor qui
proposait tellement ténue tellement
étroits que il va pas passer au travers
d'habitat propice pour la rumeur d'après
le ministère de la faune au québec 20%
des rainette faux grillon vivent dans ce
secteur ici et lise allard radio canada
longueuil